dos bloques están conectados por una
cuerda de masa insignificante que pasa
sobre dos poleas sin masa que giran con
fricción es significante como se muestra
en la figura de arriba que está aquí la
masa m2 del bloque 2 es más grande que
la masa m 1 del bloque 1 los bloques se
liberan del reposo veamos rápidamente
que es lo que pensamos que está pasando
aquí el bloque 2 tiene más masa y está
conectado con una cuerda a este sistema
de poleas tiene mayor masa pero está en
el mismo campo gravitacional por lo que
pesará más así que el peso que jala
hacia abajo la masa 2 es más grande que
el peso en la masa del bloque 1 el
bloque 2 se va a acelerar hacia abajo y
el bloque 1 se va a acelerar hacia
arriba con la misma magnitud que la del
bloque 2 esta es la situación inicial
esta es nuestra intuición sobre lo que
pensamos que va a ocurrir aquí ahora
vamos a resolver lo que nos piden en el
inciso a los puntos de abajo estos de
acá representan los dos bloques
dibuja diagramas de cuerpo libre
mostrando y etiquetando las fuerzas no
los componentes ejercidas sobre cada
bloque dibuja las longitudes relativas
de todos los vectores para reflejar las
magnitudes relativas de todas las
fuerzas veamos cuáles son las fuerzas
que están actuando sobre cada uno de
estos bloques tendremos la fuerza de
gravedad que actúa en cada uno de estos
bloques tendremos el peso de los bloques
actuando en ellos por ejemplo para este
primer bloque el bloque 1 m 1
voy a dibujarlo aquí la fuerza de
gravedad va a ser su masa m 1 por el
campo gravitacional ahora la fuerza de
gravedad para el bloque 2 es más grande
que la anterior por lo que vamos a
dibujar la así y es m2 por g y sabemos
que es más grande porque m2 es más
grande que m 1 y estamos en el mismo
campo gravitacional pero
no terminamos aquí ya que también
tenemos la fuerza que va hacia arriba
por la tensión en la cuerda vamos a
pensar en la magnitud que tendrá esta
fuerza para cada bloque para el bloque 1
sabemos que se va a acelerar hacia
arriba pues es lo que nuestra intuición
nos dice que va a pasar la magnitud de
la atención aquí tiene que ser mayor que
la magnitud del peso y para que el
bloque 2 vaya hacia abajo la magnitud de
la atención tiene que ser menor que la
de la fuerza que va hacia abajo por la
gravedad aquí en la fuerza de tensión
tiene que ser menor que la fuerza de
gravedad así que la magnitud de la
atención se encuentra entre estos dos
pesos vamos a dibujarlo la magnitud de
la tensión en el bloque 1 es mayor que m
1 por g pero menor que m2 por g algo así
esta es mi tensión y de este lado
tenemos la misma magnitud de la tensión
que jala hacia arriba pero ahora es
menor que el peso de manera que el
bloque se va a hacer
hacia abajo sabemos que la magnitud de
estas dos tensiones va a ser la misma
porque la magnitud de la atención en
toda esta cuerda va a ser la misma
cuando pensamos en la atención en esta
fuerza que jala y nos imaginamos lo que
sucede a nivel molecular es que los
enlaces covalentes se jalan entre sí a
través de toda la cuerda si lo vemos a
nivel macroscópico lo veremos como
tensión aquí hemos dibujado las fuerzas
involucradas pero las hemos dibujado en
el lugar incorrecto
ahora vamos a dibujarlas aquí abajo de
hecho puedo dibujarlas con mayor
precisión porque tenemos estas líneas en
el bloque 1 tengo el peso m 1 g
también tengo la atención que voy a
dibujar con dos líneas de alto y en el
bloque 2 tenemos la misma atención o la
misma magnitud de la atención que
también jala hacia arriba y también
tenemos su peso que voy a dibujar con
tres líneas de alto m2 la dibuje tres
veces más grande que m 1 porque tiene
que ser más grande que m 1 no nos los
dicen aquí pero yo lo he dibujado así
solo nos dicen que m2 es más grande que
m 1 así que parece que tenemos bien
nuestro diagrama de fuerzas estuvo bien
nuestra intuición aquí tenemos nuestra
atención la fuerza que va hacia arriba
es más grande que el peso por lo que
nuestra fuerza neta va a ir hacia arriba
lo que acelerará nuestro bloqueo 1 hacia
arriba aquí en el bloque 2 tenemos una
fuerza neta que va hacia abajo y que
acelera hacia abajo al bloque 2 lo que
concuerda con nuestra intuición ya que
el bloque 2 pesa más que el bloque 1